فار صغير قادر على طرد رئيس وزراء من مقر
اقامته ليست احجيه وانما حدث بالفعل وفي
كندا وفق صحيفه الجارديان فان سبب قيام
سلطات الكنديه العام الماضي باغلاق مقر
رئاسه الوزراء في العاصمه كان الفئران
التي قتلت في المبنى باعداد كبيره تكدست
جثثها وخرجت منها غازات واعتبرت سام
حسب الوثائق فان هناك انتشارا كبيرا
للقوارض في المقر ولذلك تم استخدام الطعم
الامر الذي ادى الى حشود من الفئران
المتحلله والفضلات ما اثر مخاوف حقيقيه
بشان جوده الهواء رئيس الوزراء الكندي
جاستنت رودو انضى سنوات طفولته بالمبنى
حين كان والده رئيسا للوزراء لكن بعد
توليه السلطه اعلن انه لن يعود اليه فيما
قدرت لجنه الحفاظ على المباني التراثيه
تكلفه تجديده بنحو
29.7 مليون دولار
[موسيقى]